Adam GaSe here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you coach great are you doing
this I'm doing fine first up here okay
because you know I'm a Michigan
Wolverine coach and you're the owner of
your team has his name emblazoned all
over that campus how does somebody who's
born in Ypsilanti Michigan wind up at
Michigan State how does that happen
coach well you know I was seeking higher
education after Louis Michigan State not
my mom um nice which which was she was
lovely said the only thing I have in my
office really have dolphins helmet I
commissioned stay at helmet which this
Ross loves when he wants me I usually
try to wear Michigan State apparel as
much as possible when he comes in the
building now I mean the boss is the boss
is cool looks beyond yeah he loved he
loved it because he gets it gets
everything going he's holding last year
with my head pretty good though yeah I
know that was at least one turning of
the worm for the Michigan program
happened last year but you did wind up
on the staff of Nick Saban while he was
there correct that's where you sort of
got your coaching start in a way yeah I
was a student assistant there for my
entire college college time for years
and that's really how I got involved in
this sport and and just so much so much
that I learned was in those four years
and then being able to follow Nick to
LSU that was three more years of you
know I always looked at as I was getting
a PhD in coaching
well how much Saban is in you coach I
think a lot of a lot of this situation
and organizational things that I learned
from him have really really helped me in
the current job I have right now I don't
think about what a senior seen a lot of
the things that that occurred and heard
him teach the way that he he that he
teaches situational football to the to
our to our players I think that would
have been a big chunk that I missed out
on and I was I was lucky I was in the
right place right time and then when it
came time for you to join the ranks of
the National Football League if I'm not
mistaken the first man who who gave you
that
is the best man of Tom Izzo's from back
in the day in Mariucci my guy from game
day morning on the network is that true
coach correct correct I had this little
six month window there of a internship
and mooch just got hired and I don't
know if you remember it was it was late
because it was after the Senior Bowl
that staff actually coached and Senior
Bowl in Detroit and then they fired
coach morning wig after the Senior Bowl
and then mooch got hired and they were
trying to kind of organize some things
and they needed a couple of interns so a
guy named Bobby Merritt and myself were
hired as a six-month interns to put all
these point of attack tapes together for
for the draft and that was that was
really in and it was hey I have a chance
to go back to Michigan so I don't make
it at least I'm not far from home I can
what you learn from mooch so few people
talk about what they've learned from
mooch you know and so many people got
their start thanks to Steve I'd love to
get something from you what you saw
watching Mariucci work up close as a
coach in the NFL Adam GaSe I think it
was the first time that I was around
somebody that was as tight as he was
with his coaching staff and the way that
he interacted with the players in the
way that he was able to have great
relationships with players but at the
same time so be a an authority figure he
had a great way to to balance that and
it was my first exposure to somebody
where players loved that he was hit
their head coach and you know he had a
great way about how he interacted with
everybody in the building because you've
been around him for a long time now in
it there you can't find anybody to say a
bad word about he's one of my favorite
one loves them and they gravitate to him
and and that was a I would just see how
he treated everybody great he treated
from from the lowest person intern and
the fact that he knew who I was and
where I
from and and where I come from and he
would he would talk to everybody and it
was you just felt like you are a part of
it and I that was something that I was
so glad I experienced because it's
really helped me as my careers evolved
and getting to this spot and now the
spot being the Miami Dolphins Adam GaSe
joining me here so even though you went
ten and six you made the playoffs what
did you now having one year as the head
coach of a team in the National Football
League do you think of going into year
two saying that you're going to focus
better on this or need to focus on on
that what's the what's your adjustment
going into year two our routine now is a
coaching staff we have a way better feel
of how we can work together where that
first year you're trying you're kind of
going through the bumps in the road of
especially with me with the offense of
what my schedule is how I can I have to
jump in and out and how we can kind of
put game plans together and same thing
with the defense my interaction with
them in special teams it's everything is
moving so fast and it's just a non-stop
process and and just now we have a
really good feel of how that works you
know there's not dead time and that's
that's the key to the entire NFL is when
you start having those little dead
windows where guys aren't there like
where are we going next and you feel
like you have no direction that's where
it gets it's just it crushes you because
there is no room for that and you you
constantly have to keep moving that's
why when you hear that guys talk about
how many hours everything is it's it's
non-stop you walk in the building to the
time you leave you just feel like you're
never stopped well last year we spoke
with Cameron Wake and gamma could sue on
this show
coach gates and both of them said a
major point of your season last year was
when you started telling vets take a
seat we're going to start using some
guys that have earned the time based on
the way that I'm seeing them practice
and play like Tony Lippett from Michigan
state being one of those guys that you
threw out there at corner how difficult
was that for you to do so quickly on in
your head coaching career last year you
know we first started our program that
was something that we had talked about
from Mike Tannenbaum Chris Greer myself
to where we were going to focus on where
you were drafted where you changed from
whether you've been here whether it came
from somewhere else or we really didn't
we really didn't care we told everybody
it's a clean slate whoever you are
from this moment on that's what we're
going to evaluate that's what we're
going to judge off of and a lot of guys
took took that ran with it and and
jumped on that opportunity some guys
that took a little longer than others
and some guys ended up not being here
because of it and I think players
appreciate that the best players play
and they know that there there's the
whole drafted first-round all those
types of things are irrelevant here we
were all worried about one thing and
that's doing everything we can to win
and you know if you're not on that train
then then they you know just let us know
we'll let you move on to somewhere else
well the big question a lot of Dolphins
fans have coach cases will Tannehill
have a similar set of parameters placed
on him this year that if he's not
performing to a certain level at the
quarterback position by week's X Y or Z
that somebody else is going to get a
chance what do you say to that yeah I
have a lot of confidence that Ryan's
going to do exactly what we need him to
do to be you know an impact player for
us and you know Ryan puts himself in
position what the way works weighted
Studies on and off the field
he does all the little details right and
that's why you see usually the guys that
end up moving in and out of the lineup
it's there's things behind the scenes
that have occurred that has you know
forced forced a hand for some move and
he puts himself in such a good position
that my confidence level in him is so
high he's you know you start putting
guys in buckets of when it gets when
gets kind of kind of
thick and tough and you know there's
adversity you know he's in that bucket
with with a lot of other guys to wear
you know he's going to get the job done
where did what does he need to do coach
I mean you know what an elite
quarterback looks like you you've uh
you've been right there hip to hip with
Peyton Manning what is that what is ten
he'll do you do like you're fine
sometimes it's it's it's time time in
the system time of you know which
experience in the NFL you know I mean
we're talking about a guy going into his
fifth year go I mean Matt Ryan got
dressed in 2008 and eight years later
he's an NFL MVP you know and his road
wasn't as smooth as we remember last
year I mean there was there were some
ups there were some downs
he kept battling finding ways to keep
compete get better learn from his
experiences that's that's what that's
what this profession is all about it's
it when the adversity hits how are you
going to handle it and how are you going
to keep battling and when everybody's
down on you are you going to put your
head down and crawl in the hole or you
know you know keep pushing ahead and
being the first a through the wall a
couple of minutes left with Adam GaSe
Dolphins head coach here so much made of
Odell Beckham sitting up there in New
York City and you've got yourself a
dynamic wide receiver from the same
school same cloth it seems that Jarvis
Landry has been cut from down there in
South Florida doesn't get nearly as much
attention that said do you think Jarvis
Landry sometimes needs to take the pill
of the chill variety to try and maintain
a composure or
you think this is the way he is and
you're just going to let it fly your
coach I love the way that Jarvis does
everything I love the way he plays in
games in his intensity level and guys
feed off of the way that that he plays
and occasionally when we when we get a
personal foul post touchdown he knows
that that frustrates me slightly I'd
rather him not one loses money on
something that is very easily
preventable for himself um but it's it's
hard for me to to want to change the way
in plays when I love the waiting place
and I love his passion and I love I love
his intensity every you know gain and
day out especially on Sundays he it goes
up a level which is unbelievable that
that actually happens because you so
intense all the other times and you know
that's one of the things that we try to
allow guys that you know in our program
that we want them to be themselves we
don't want them to be somebody they're
not and you know but at the end of the
day everything is about what's best for
the team when it comes comes the winning
and if we can prevent personal files
that's exactly what we want to we want
to make sure that we're doing but it you
know at the same time I don't want him
to lose his intensity and what are you
telling your team about the relaxed
celebration rules certainly in light of
the fact that a 40-second clock is going
to start the minute a touchdown is
signaled by an official and if there's
no replay that clocks going to tick and
somebody's got to kick an extra point
within those 40 seconds that somebody
also might be celebrating what are you
telling your team I'm not going to make
a big deal about it because if that
clock ever expires they're going to have
to deal with our special teams coach so
I'm a lot I'm a lot easier to deal with
than our special teams coach because
he'll be on the 15 on the numbers doing
a lot of em essing so I'm pretty sure
that we will be in inside the framework
of the clock okay so you're just going
to leave that up right there just leave
that I think if I started dressing
dressing anything with what's my guys
it's just when it comes to something
like that it's our guys will do they'll
do the right thing because they just
know it's about winning and we're not
going to want to take penalties on
something that's it's black and white we
know what the rule is you know we have
to we have to adjust to what the rule is
and make sure we handle it correctly all
right Darren rizzi is that who you're
leaving it up to coach frizzy it so
you're saying I'm not leaving it up
there they know who they have to deal
with okay very good
last one for you coach Adam GaSe Jay
Cutler in the broadcast booth now I
don't usually ask head coaches sports
television questions but that said
you've been watching TV and sports TV
I'm sure
for all your your life how good you
think a job cut was going to do in the
booth as an analyst he'll do it he'll do
a good job he's he's not short of
comments trust me okay I'd be afraid if
I was calling it calling plays and he
was announcing the game because I'm
pretty sure he'll be very critical if
it's my play calling for sure okay and I
I think he'll do a great job because
he'll put the time in he'll work at it
you know he'll want to be good at it and
if if he if he decided if he decided
that that's what he wanted to do you're
not going to get a product out there
that is going to be short in any kind of
effort coach I've really enjoyed this
conversation thanks so much
Michigan and Michigan State can have a
conversation of a certain length that I
think we can agree was intelligent
top-notch friendly I would think that
leaves room for from war yes
absolutely absolutely I appreciate a
rich and you got it you got it say hello
to mr. Ross for me he's all over campus
I will promise you got it that's Adam
GaSe Dolphins head coach so Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy